but a lot of people sneak it though like
everyone is pretty open about how they
try to sneak it I'm not going to do none
of that dude my my ex accidentally
brought cocaine to Singapore oh
[Music]
two one
how do you feel this about the state of
America how do you feel about the state
of not trying oh they got really good
[__]
a YouTuber is facing five years in
prison after giving his girlfriend a lap
dance where anybody oh in a Muslim
country no that's a really good game in
the mosque
oh no that's also a very good guess in
the library yeah
I like this guessing game oh yeah
an endangered animal sanctuary oh yeah
that's not a good place to do it what
kind of animal
like I don't know the the white spotted
hyenas that's dangerous
oh I know an appropriate Place
daycare
how did you insert my mind did you say
that yeah I was gonna say daycare that's
crazy great minds you guys are both
thinking about little kitties because
that's an inappropriate place to do
sexual acts oh it's not the first choice
yeah well it's actually no it's more
basic now it's not like it's a lot of
very uh amazing places it's actually a
Bangkok restaurant oh really yeah
there's out of all the places and this
guy's streamer AKA is ice Poseidon real
name Paul denino uh is somebody who like
kind of just does a lot of crazy things
he's a streamer you're not streamers get
they just do really uh jarring things in
order to get very I hate those guys but
yeah bro
I hate people that just go and like
invade other cultures and then they just
do crazy stuff to disrupt yeah just to
be correct shock streamers yeah yeah so
he uh surprised his girlfriend while
they ate at a restaurant
in Bangkok do you take his pants off
well let me just show you an image he
probably took his pants off in Bangkok
though that almost seems like it
wouldn't be he's probably in a G-string
bro so he's wearing this
um okay
what am I looking at
a man in lingerie
kind of
look I don't think you should go to jail
for five years for doing that but I
think you should lock him up for five
years for being a public annoyancy yeah
I think I think that's the law that he
broke I I will give him a show you know
I mean it's when I think about Bangkok I
think of the Las Vegas of Southeast Asia
where there's a lot of sex and partying
so I don't know and ladyboys yeah but
the thing is that just seemed like he's
having a good time in a sexual place
like if it's Amsterdam well it's a it is
a restaurant at the end of the day
um five years though well this guy this
guy came out in that sheer body stalking
um and then he received the telling off
from the manager who told him that uh
they can't do this in Thailand is it is
Thailand
what he said Furious the manager
demanded that he uh public places get a
hold of their passports and uh also she
called the police and then it ended up
the him and his kind of Entourage ended
up getting arrested the streamer writes
on social media a mug shot with
pressured admission of guilt and apology
guilty of what no idea no no one telling
me what the law was I broke
and because his lap dance was streamed
live it was revealed that he was charged
with distribution of obscene content
wow
okay I mean he was committing acts that
was trying to cause a reaction yeah and
he got a reaction a reaction yeah it's
not the desired outcome but they seem to
be really familiar with this law well
based off like his skin color I know a
lot of traits of those type of creatures
I've seen them and a lot of them are
like like I'm not touching you so what
you can do you know it's very like they
like to [__] around and find out yeah
they want to play with fire [__] up and
find out and then when they're in other
countries that's not as like Freedom
they don't [__] around they yeah you
find out real quick and you can't assume
that they do [__] around yeah you can't
assume that they're gonna be okay with
it because you're in a different country
and you have to like not be like you
could probably do that out of Walmart
you know but you go to another country
some countries will just chop her hands
off I just wonder what kind of
restaurant it is like if it's a if it's
like a Thailand Denny's why are you
doing that but it goes to Thailand
Hooters probably probably Christy poor
gang oh that's a delicious restaurant
because you know in a place that has
shows where a ping pong gets shot out of
a vagina do they really have shows like
that's the thing that's a private oh
it's private I think that's the problem
it's like even if a country has the
impression of being something yeah it's
not your right to put that out and be
like check it out yeah just because
those shows also are on Amsterdam you
can't just go to a random answer in a
restaurant and put a ping pong in your
vagina right yeah that's true
are you challenging me because I will
that's the host country doing the their
thing exactly yeah it's different when
an outsider comes in and then tries to
do something crazy but can't you just
like
it's easily I get confused right it
follows an Amsterdam and then like and
then like I'm smoking weed in like a
Denny's in Amsterdam they might be like
sir that is not right and I'm like I'm
in Amsterdam [__] and they're like real
Denny's yeah you know [__] French
manager I'll take this out elsewhere
that's the thing I think it's like the
local law is looking the other way for
their locals not for you okay yeah you
can't go to North Korea and be like I
brought a missile because you have
missile
that's the problem here like how did you
bring a missile
I love Bangkok though oh man the food oh
so good man I got to go to Bangkok get
the food
okay it is true because like even when
remember I was telling you guys when I
was performing in Dubai they had a set
of rules that we had to follow but their
people didn't have to follow oh we did
and so they said you cannot Party Rock
but we can Body Rock right
you can't even have alcohol referenced
in your lyric wow but we can drink while
you do that it's like it's a different
thing where it's not for you the guest
yeah
so you have to be halal
exactly you got to be more hello you got
to be a good boy you gotta be a sweet
sweet boy and of course you're gonna get
maximum penalty if you're an outsider
and you're making a mockery of the
culture there yeah yeah they have to
make your example out of here this
reminds me of all the other streamers
and stuff that go to like those Japanese
trains and they just try to like prey on
people's like niceness and stuff and
they just kind of make it they talk [__]
it's so angry I'm like I'm so glad that
that one streamer was getting like
[__] up every time he walked around
Japan because he was but not enough yeah
yeah they didn't go hard they were they
were actually kind of nice he wasn't
getting [__] up enough they didn't
pull Wasabi in his eyes or something
there were some guys that hit him but
like they didn't [__] them up hard
enough but they didn't like go Yakuza
the way that we were hoping yeah or lock
them up for five years no yeah exactly
but look what happened back in the day
with Singapore where the guy that got
flogged oh oh yeah well he was tagging
right if it's a chance doing graffiti
and then they yeah why are you doing
graffiti it's the nip it in the bud like
scenario where they're like this isn't
gonna be a thing yeah I think that's a
good way to stop it right I mean it did
stop it that stereotype lives on today
that you can't chew gum people really
think you're gonna get your ass beat for
that I don't chew gummies anymore
you can chew gum when we go back to
Singapore all my uncles that's my mom
like can you bring us some chewing gum
when they get it are they like no it's
not oh
it's illegal to spit it out yeah you're
not supposed to spit in general but you
can't really you can't really buy gum
anywhere over there can you yeah you can
yeah I did yeah they had black black
what's that it's a gum brand yeah oh the
Japanese yeah oh well I also know now
not to bring any weed cartridges to
Russia
I'm glad they cleared that up because it
was such a gray area
that's it bro have you ever accidentally
smuggled things like that Nick
one time accidentally in like a like a
actual Pen cartridge was in my my
carry-on bag the whole time and I
traveled to many different states and
through TSA and no one said anything
what domestically and International
International is where it gets scary I
had no idea I probably don't know what
that is just yeah well but five years
ago absolutely nowadays now everybody's
starting to learn but a lot of people
sneak it though like everyone is pretty
open about how they try to sneak it I'm
not gonna do none of that dude my my ex
accidentally brought cocaine to
Singapore oh accident like honest
accident but she got it through good
they didn't check they didn't check
because oh so super [__] lucky dude
so lucky dude she had it in her actual
checked bag double lucky because she
didn't get caught and she gets to use it
insane because there's no trial for that
you just go die no and you're a
foreigner oh my god well she's from vet
she was Vancouver but shanghainese oh
yeah dude what's her first last name you
know it you know them both
things like that something wrong I
almost brought a live ammunition to
Australia
but no gun just ammunition thank God I
didn't have a gun because
um I had a magazine full like because I
went shooting the other day I used my
backpack and then I used the same
backpack to travel and I didn't clean it
out and then I took the gun out
and then when I went through TSA they're
like sir do you have anything I should
know about and I'm all like no I just
thought it was one of those routine
stops and then she goes sir
you have a fully loaded clip and I was
like actually it's magazine but I I have
a paperwork and I was like
oh [__] I'm going to Australia I was
like I I think this is legal there so I
wouldn't even be able to bring it in if
I put it on my check-in so I was like
you could have it she goes are you sure
you could put it in your back and I'm
like nah where I'm going I can't bring
that
so I just let them keep it damn but the
lady in front of me she was looking
horrified like what the [__] it's gonna
blow the plate up oh [__] that's a
grenade that lady was holding it like
with the pliers thing just dangling it
oh my God she's like sir you have a
fully loaded clip and she was all
dangling it like this and I'm like oh I
was shooting you that I forgot
but the fact is she was so like oh you
could put it in your carry-on I mean
you're checking you could take it back
like because yeah because you can right
you can like it's yeah but the the
person that was in it they're just like
oh my god what the [__] oh yeah might
get into trouble in Australia I don't
know oh yeah yeah I'm glad that they
caught it because what if I came into
Australia with that yeah I know right
yeah I would have been a deep ass [__]
because they get angry like off of
oranges yeah oh yeah they get angry yeah
I do get caught you just say I'm here to
shoot rabbits here they probably let you
in
foreign
[Music]